ENFORCEMENT TO MONITOR SOCIAL
ASK BECAUSE HERE PARTS OF THE
CITY WERE RANSACWIIEVES TARGETE
ACIES AND AN APPLE
OR
POLICE SAY THETAZED THEIR PLAN
THE MORE THAN 50 FOLKS
BROADCAST WHND NFLUENCER.
LOCATIONOOT.
>> EVERYBODY WANTS WAS LATER AR
WHAT THE PHILADELPHIA INQUIRER .
SHE DECLINED C REQUEMMENT,TVT
ADVISED HER NOT TO DO
INWS.IN PHILADELPHIA
ISN'T EN ARE WKING T
ORGANIZED IMORNCIME FOR PERPETR
R OCIAL
MEDIA.
WITH WITH MORE PEOPLE POSTING
CRIMES PUBLICLY ONLINE OR USING
SOCIAL MEDIA AS A L,
MONITOR ACCOUN FEATS OR T
CRIMINAL ACTIVY.BUT THRE FACING
INFRINGE ON YO RO IT'SY FOR THEE
TAKE BOSTON AS O E.
$1O BEEF UP ITS  MONITORT CK TH
AFTER BACKLA FROM THE ACLU WHO
SAID IT ULD IL
AND TARGET COMMUNITY           G
MUSLIMS AND COLOR.
NEW YORK HAMPED UP THEIR
IGNING A
USES AI TO MONITOR ONLINE
BEHAVIOR.
ANS T BYUND A
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMT ORIN
CI
MEDIA WITHOUT IN
MONITORING OF E TUIVELY OF THE D
WOFE AND PROTECTING ACRIGHTS, A
CHALLENGE EVERY DAY.
S THE NI THE LIBERTY
D NATIONAL SECURITY PROGRAM AT
THE BRENNAN CENTERBEING HERE.
TO ME, IEMNATURAL, LOGICAL LAW
FOSOCIAL TS OF INDIVIDUALS TH
KNOW, SUSPECNVOLVED IN
ACTIVITY.
TOLICE OUGHT TO BE
THERE TOEE
WHAT AM I GETTING WRONG?TTYTHIN
IT JT THAT THAT'S NOT
NLY THING THATE SOCIAL
A TH
IF YOU THINK ABOUT INVTINT.
YOU KNOW OF SOMED
G THATS POING
THINGS ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT
MIGHT BE REL
IFOU KNOTH THAT IS A OULD BET TT
OR AONTI
ORGAZEAND THE COPS
WANT TO KN DO
WE NEEAVE OUT THER
THE POTENTIAL THAT THINGS
MIGHT GET OUT OF HAND,
ABSOLUTELY
U O SOTO DO .
UNFORTUNATE
MEDIA TO MON , BECAUSE THE RULAS
MOVE
THOCA TONGD IT GET
DERAILED?
MONITORILATER TAGS, AS WELL AS .
THE SAME T I
LAPD.
IT'S NOTT WED TOE CRIMERE WORRID
EVIDENCEY  I.
IN EXAMPLE YOU ?
ARTICULATED OR AL
A GROUTH SESOCIAL
THERE'S REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF ITS MEMBERS.
THEN WHAT?
THEN VE THELIO  YOU HAVTO
RULES ARND
THAT'S WHERE MLICE
FALL DOWN.
THS THAT THEY HAE.
MONITIN
USEFUL.
YOU'RE IT.
BUT IN FACT, IF YOU'RE UBLIC SA
ORE AFRAID THERE
BE SOM, WHAT'S T
PROTEST IS DONE, YOU DON'T NEED
DO AEE DATA ORNE CREATIN
UESTION OF HOW
TO MAKE SU THA UAL
L, PUT NOT USE
IT TO INFR ON PEOPLE'S FIRST
THE FLY HHINK'RE REMINDING ME
I'M RIGHT.
THE  C THERE WAS
A SUPREME COURCASE.
ITDRENT CAN HINK THIS IS FAIR FI
FOLLOW YOU AS YOU GO ABOUTBUSINR
PS TRACKER ON YOUR
CAR, THERE HASNG
TO
BECAUSE THIS INDIVIDL S
BEEN I
INSTAGRAM
ISPUING THHERE'S WHERE WE SHLD .
AND  IN MY ANALYSIS, THAT'S
THSEF LAW ENFORCEMENWNTR'TANYTH
ONLANCE
TECHNOLOGY OVER THE LASTPLDECAD
SURVEILLCE THINKABOUT REI CATHEG
WARRANT.
NOW WHAT WE'RE LT  MORE IS PUBLC
WHICH IS THE ABILITYLOGY TO TRAP
GENEY KNOWING,NE, GPS, THOSE
KINDS OFOLOGIES.
FALSLIGHTLY
PLACE BECAUSE IN THOSE
THEANCES, YOU'RE NOTIVELY VEALY
WHERCI.
PUTTING INFORMATION OUT THER
SO I THINK IE TO LO SOCIAL
NEEDO E TH ONS IN PLACE SO THAT
THAT ACCES USED TO
MONITOPROTESTERS ANDEOE E EXERC.
ITRO T MXAMPLE
INQUIRER ABOUT WHAT NTRE.
THIS WAS SOME OFWA
SAID IN SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHAT TIM
WE LOOTING OR
I KNOWHEG UP OUR
THE ONLY W TRI
I'M ING THERE'S A COP
WITH A SMART PHONE IN A POLICE
L WHO IS ALSING THIS AND
T XTTHWORD
WHAT DID MOST WA TSECOND THINK
FOR FIGHTING CRIME, I THINK
CLEAR DAAND SAFEGUARMES